- What were your like pop
culture, obsessions, growing up?
- I didn't really have any.
I just loved Star Wars
and Lord of the Rings.
- So you're sci-fi, all right!
- Yeah, but I wasn't
like, obsessed with them.
People were obsessed with the Spice Girls
when I was growing up
and I would attend
these Spice Girl parties
and do the thing and dress up.
And I was Sporty Spice
because I played sports,
so it was one I could understand the most.
And then we had to do these
music videos, you know,
fake music videos at friends' birthdays,
and I don't know any of the words.
And I just,
everyone had an obsession as a child
and I feel like I didn't.
And I feel like I've
lost out on something.
- No, it's so funny.
So right whenever I got in the industry,
I would have to go on
TRL and all the video,
like I didn't have, we had
like the basic eight channels.
So I didn't really know about pop culture
because we were poor.
Like, and we didn't, I
didn't read magazines.
We didn't have the internet
like how we have it now,
whenever I was little.
So I just didn't know.
And like, I remember being
on TRL and they'll be like,
"What are your favorite videos?"
And you're trying not to offend
MTV, but I didn't see one!
And I was trying to ask
the person over here,
"What was your favorite?"
You know, which one I loved.
And then I'd just say whatever they said.
So I wasn't really that into it either.
I was very creative on my own,
were you kind of that kid,
that kind of just did whatever?
I played sports as well.
Were you that kid that
beat to your own drum?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- I was an athlete and I was a dancer
and I was obsessed with
whatever thing I was practicing,
but you brought up MTV and it,
I just need to let you know that we went,
my fiance and I went
down a big rabbit hole
of you on MTV and on SNL
singing Since You've Been Gone.
(Kelly laughs)
It is, we just like,
couldn't stop watching
old videos of you singing.
They're just,
it's so phenomenal and emotional
and made us cry every time.
- Oh my gosh!
- Such great vintage MTV,
not vintage because it
was like 10 years ago.
- No it wasn't, it's vintage!
And what's crazy though,
is you'll experience this in your life,
you'll have done a project years ago,
which you probably have already,
and you're like,
it's such a different
chapter of your life.
It's like different chapters in your book
and it's cool, but it's good
to make sure you slow down,
'cause I think I'm quite
a bit older than you,
I'm like at least a decade.
And I think it's good to like slow down
and enjoy all those moments.
'cause sometimes I didn't
because you're always worried
about your next project or
your next thing, but yeah,
I do remember getting to
trash a whole apartment
in that video, which was cool.
I was like, "I get paid to do this?"
So what about, what about a
favorite classic sitcom though?
Because you have so many sitcoms,
I feel like they're pulling
from so many sitcoms for WandaVision.
Did you have any, like
I loved, I Love Lucy.
I was obsessed.
Did you love any like classic ones?
- I loved Laverne and Shirley,
but I grew up with like the nineties ones.
So The Torkelsons was like a,
was a family show
that was really sincere.
- [Kelly] Wait, the what?
- I don't know.
I, my best friend and I believe
the mom of The Torkelsons,
'cause we're from the valley,
lived on his street or we
saw her on his street once,
and it was,
that was like the most exciting
person we could have seen
because her daughter speaks
to the man in the moon
and we just, it was, it was very exciting.
The Torkelsons was, I don't know.
I don't even know if
we liked it ironically
or if we understood irony at that age,
but we loved The Torkelsons.
- I'm totally gonna YouTube
that tonight and be like,
what are you talking about?
I've never heard of it.